[Musique]
Je m'appelle Wade Watts, je choisirais ce
nom parce qu'il ressemblait à
l'alter ego d'un super-héros comme Peter Parker
ou Bruce Banner, mais il est mort quand j'étais
enfant, ma mère aussi et je me suis retrouvé ici
assis ici mon  petit calme sorti de nulle part
il n'y a nulle part où aller
[Musique]
nulle part
sauf l'Oasis
[Musique
] tout un univers virtuel
[Musique]
viennent à l'Oasis pour tout ce
qu'ils peuvent faire
ils restent parce que tout ce qu'ils
peuvent être  pouvez-vous ressentir cette
[musique]
ouais le seul endroit qui donne l'impression que je veux
dire l'Oasis était l'idée originale de
James Halliday Oh si vous regardez
ça je suis mort
j'ai créé un objet caché un œuf de Pâques
la première personne à trouver l'œuf
héritera d'un demi-billion de dollars et du
contrôle total de l'Oasis lui-même
qui est-ce possible comment diable
gagne-t-il
[Musique]
- des trucs de vie ou de mort l'Oasis la
recherche économique la plus importante au monde
il n'y a rien de moins qu'une guerre pour le
contrôle de  le futur
bienvenue dans la rébellion attendre
[Musique]
quelque chose de
plus grand que moi
êtes-vous prêt à
nous aider à sauver l'oasis
vous
[Musique]
nous sommes nés dans un monde en guerre entre
les monstres qui avaient détruit nos
villes et les monstres que nous avons créés pour
arrêtez-les, nous pensions avoir
suffisamment sacrifié, mais le mur que nous pensions avoir
terminé ne fait que commencer et la seule
chose qui se tient devant l'
apocalypse
[Musique],
c'est nous,
mais peu importe d'où vous venez,
nous avons cru en vous et qui l'a fait
ce n'est pas notre moment c'est notre chance de
faire une différence
faisons-le
ma balle
tombe
ils ont développé un blanc d'œuf toute la vie
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose que vous devez voir
bien il est assez grand
toi,
il y avait une idée de réunir un
groupe de personnes remarquables pour voir si nous
pouvions devenir quelque chose de plus, alors quand ils
avaient besoin de nous, nous pourrions mener les
batailles qu'ils n'ont jamais pu
[Musique]
[Musique
] avec le temps, vous saurez ce que c'est que de
perdre sentir si désespérément que vous êtes  Nous
avons
encore raison d'échouer tout ce temps
[Applaudissements]
fuyez Dustin est toujours arrivé
évacuez la ville
et fermez nos défenses
et obtenez ce plaisir Manish
[Musique]
n'est pas quelque chose que l'on considère de l'
univers d'équilibrage
[Applaudissements]
avec cela
fait sourire  sur mon visage
[Musique]
l'enfer êtes-vous les gars
vous
quel est votre nom Laura nom de famille Croft
Lara votre père est parti vous pourriez reprendre
là où il s'est arrêté
je le vois tellement en vous
brillant bonjour pousse si vous
écoutez  ceci alors je dois être mort
j'ai trouvé quelque chose un outil appelé la
mère de la mort si Trinity réussit notre
monde est en danger promets-moi que tu
arrêteras je promets je pense que je sais où mon
père est allé c'est en plein milieu de
la mer du diable ça va  être une aventure la
mort n'est pas plus chaude que l'
aventure  le destin de l'humanité est
maintenant entre vos mains  ds
[Musique]
ne fais pas trop attention ces jours-ci le
monde est devenu complètement fou j'en prendrai deux
j'ai vu des dieux voler j'ai vu des hommes construire des
armes que je ne pouvais même pas imaginer
j'ai vu des extraterrestres  tomber du ciel ouais
mais je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel à
quel point boy ID
[Musique]
nous sommes à la maison
mon fils c'est à
toi de décider quel genre de roi tu
vas être ne gèle pas je ne gèle jamais
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne pas être télévisé
montrez-moi mon respect en Belgique
parce que nous possédons ouais j'ai attendu toute ma vie
pour ça
le monde va recommencer je vais tout brûler
ce qui se passe maintenant détermine ce qui se passe
[Musique]
au reste de la  monde
amusons-nous
[Musique]
alors euh qu'est-ce que tu sors comme un
comptable maintenant Ellen ventriloque Sapa
tu aimes un mannequin ce n'est pas pourquoi nous sommes
ici
[Musique]
Je sais pourquoi nous sommes ici
un  opération de sauvetage sauver les dinosaures de l'
île qui est sur le point d'exploser ce qui
pourrait mal tourner
bleu est vivant tu l'as élevée faire ces
animaux de  servent les mêmes protections
accordées aux autres espèces ou devraient-elles
simplement être laissées pour mortes ces créatures étaient
ici avant nous
si nous ne faisons pas attention
elles seront ici après que
vous me connaissiez
[Musique] la
vie ne peut pas être méprisée la vie se
libère la vie trouve  loin
[Musique]
c'est bizarre que tu aimes traîner avec des
animaux plus qu'avec des gens ouais
eh bien les animaux me sauvent George d'
ici avait 2 ans
George n'aurait jamais survécu tout
seul il te fait définitivement confiance la nuit dernière
George  était de sept pieds qui pesait 500
livres George tu es d'accord mon pote tu as
peur tout va bien
ce matin est neuf pieds poussant
mille ce qui arrive à mon ami
êtes-vous familier avec l'édition génétique
les changements seront incroyablement
imprévisibles
est-il le seul oh tu ne l'as pas fait  Je ne sais pas
pour le loup de 30
pieds  e le monde
ça me revient
tu dois évacuer Chicago George
n'a pas demandé ça ils vont
les abattre
ça n'arrive pas il
y a quelque chose dans cette rivière je
pensais juste que la seule chose qui
manquait dans la maison un  crocodile géant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce matin j'ai réveillé
ma souris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends alors combien d'entre nous
vous pouvez décrire sa chute pas de recommencer depuis
le début que pensez-vous que je fais
quand vous  es absent tu penses que je suis dehors dans
le jardin en train de regarder le ciel pourquoi
es-tu ici je dois partir un jour plus tôt
[Musique]
ton mari est là laisse moi le voir il est
extrêmement malade tu dois me dire
pourquoi  faisait c'était sa
décision d'y aller
c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont appelé le miroitement que
nous avons envoyé des drones dans des équipes de personnes
mais rien ne revient mais quelque chose a
tu es un biologiste qui a servi dans l'
armée si je savais ce qui s'est passé j'ai
sauvé  sa vie
la limite s'agrandit elle
s'étend  ding nous parlons des villes États
vous devez savoir ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur c'est
beau
vérifiez cela on dirait qu'ils sont coincés
dans une rotation continue sont-ils
comprendre qu'ils ne sont pas des requins ont des dents
comme ça pas possible vous ne pouvez pas traverser de
grandes bases de différence  oui
eh bien les soldats de la dernière expédition
sont devenus fous ou quelque chose ici les tue
quelque chose est passé à travers la clôture
tu es la clôture
nous devons y retourner je ne peux pas y retourner
nous pouvons camper ici ce soir
ça détruit tout ça ne détruit pas
ça fait quelque chose
nouvelle musique]